Marvel Studios surprised everyone with
the announcement that Avengers ends game
is getting a re-release just two months
after the film at theaters Marvel
initially didn't say a whole lot about
the new version of endgame but now the
studio has revealed what audiences will
see upon the big screen in a press
release rolled out on June 25th Marvel
detailed that things will kick off with
a video introduction from Avengers
endgame co-director Anthony Russo the
film will then roll out just as it
always has with no additional footage
included things got exciting after the
credits roll though when an unfinished
Elite it seen place else Marvel Studios
didn't mention what happens in the clip
but the folks out we got this covered
they're claiming that it focuses on Mark
Ruffalo Hulk as of now it's unclear what
the big green guy will get up to in this
never-before-seen sequence but we'd love
to see Bruce Banner working in his lab
to combine his brains with the Brawn of
the Hulk
similarly Marvel didn't say anything in
his press release about attributes but
we do know that it's definitely coming
based on phii's past comments MCU cosmic
reports for the tribute is a homage to
than other than Stan Lee the longtime
creative leader of Marvel Comics who
helped create several of our favorite
superheroes Lee died at the age of 95 on
November 12th 2018 only a handful of
months before the theatrical debuts of
Captain Marvel and the Avengers endgame
is a mystery what exactly the tributes
and tales but it seems likely that the
clip will touch on these incredible
contributions for the world of comics
plus it might even take a look back on
the many film cameos he made through
other Marvel Cinematic Universe an
unfinished scrub sequence that
apparently centers on Hulk definitely
sounds intriguing
but it may disappoint fans who are
hoping to finally see the scene
featuring Catherine Lankford as a
teenage Morgan Stark the 13 reasons why
actress was meant to appear to Tony
Stark in a vision after he uses a
gauntlet and snaps his fingers on an
episode of the podcast habits are
confused Joe Russo stated that Tony
would have seen an older Morgan and the
very same metaphysical weigh station but
Thanos went to after he conducted his
own snap in Avengers infinity war
attention was that his future daughter
forgave him and sort of gave him peace
judo right now there's no way to know
for sure whether the deleted scene is
all about professor Hulk or not so
there's a chance that this scene could
be the one shown during the Avengers and
the game we release if it isn't the
older Morgan sequel
could be included in the home release of
the film the final kiddie tucked into
the Avengers end game we released that
Marvel has confirmed is a special sneak
peek at the next MCU movie spider-man
far from home with you out in theaters
on July 2nd bringing endgame back into
theaters just days before far from home
opens as a risky move since fans could
overlook the Spidey sequel in favor of
seeing endgame again thankfully it looks
like Marvel is using the re-release as a
way to boost hype for Peter Parker's
second MTU solo outing however an
introduction clip a deleted scene as
spider-man far from home teased and a
tribute montage may not be enough to
attract viewers that could pose a
problem since he appears at Marvel's
main reason for be releasing Avengers
endgame is to earn enough money to beat
out avatar and become the biggest movie
of all time at least those who do decide
to give endgame another watch won't
leave the cinema empty-handed we release
attendees will receive an exclusive
Avengers poster in select theaters while
supplies last Plex the Avengers end game
we released starting on Friday June 28th
check out one of our newest videos right
here Plus even more looper videos but
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you